Hello and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I am your host Rawk ode.
Today we're gonna be taking a look at
Kyverno,
a CNCF sandbox project that aims to bring
policy management to Kubernetes clusters in a Kubernetes
way.
Today I am joined by Jim and shooting
from the Kyverno team. Hi there both, how
are you?
Doing great. Thank you.
Awesome.
Before we begin, let's just take a moment
to have you both introduce yourself. We'll start
with Jim since you're next to me there
on the screen and then we'll move over
and take it away.
Alright. Hi everyone. I'm Jim Beglaudia, co founder
and CEO at Nirmata and one of the
maintainers on Kyverno.
Alright.
Hi everyone. This is Xu Lin Zhao. I'm
a software engineer at the and
I helped quit Kyverno
and now I'm one of the maintainer of
this project.
Awesome. Thank you very much.
So today we're taking a look at Kyverno
and I think if we can just maybe
start with, you know, what is it, what
problem does it solve
and give people a bit of a flavor
and a history of why this is important
to them and the way that Kyverno solves
it. And to do that, I believe we've
got a few slides so we can get
them up on the screen and we'll get
started.
Sounds good.
Yeah, so yeah, just a little bit about
the, like you said, like the history of
the
project, what problem it solves,
why some decisions were made and how it
was designed, right? So first off, Kyverno,
as you mentioned as a policy engine, it's
designed specifically for Kubernetes.
So
unlike
OPA,
which is a general purpose policy engine and
can work with other systems,
Kyverno is specifically designed to work with Kubernetes
itself.
And that has some trade offs, right, which
are important to consider.
The the
advantage
being Kyverno can take it, you know, sort
of leverage
all of the Kubernetes ways of doing things.
Right? So it can deeply understand Kubernetes patterns,
it can plug in into other things
and leverage some of those design ideas, concepts,
and just the way how Kubernetes does things.
And
the end goal is to be very familiar
to Kubernetes users.
And we'll look at some of these examples
as we go through.
But stepping back and thinking why policies, right?
So Kubernetes is fantastic, has
a lot of power, why do we need
policies at all?
So one of the aspects of Kubernetes,
I'm sure folks have heard is the
declarative
configuration
nature of Kubernetes itself,
right? So you declare the end state you
want and then the Kubernetes controllers
work hard on your behalf to achieve that
end state
based on whatever task they're trying to perform.
But this also sort of has the side
effect of
creating a lot of configuration options, right? Everything
you want to specify
or every state you might desire,
you can now declare in the configuration.
And often what happens is within a resource,
there's some
sort of lack of separation of concerns because
you might have certain configurations that your operators
care about
while other configurations
options which your developers care about, but they're
all sort of within that same resource.
So these are the sort of challenges that
policies address very well. And regardless of which
policy choose your tool,
the idea is to be able to validate
and increasingly,
well, Kyverno has always support mutate, but now
gatekeeper also supports that. So these type of
options you can make very easy and then
also do advanced operations.
Kyverno supports like dynamic configurations,
generation,
things like that.
So
the whole idea behind Kyverno was to make
policy management Kubernetes native,
to make policies declarative themselves.
So you're really expressing what you want to
achieve and then Kyverno does that on your
behalf
rather than having to program
and write imperative logic to create these policies.
So that's one of the kind of trade
offs to think about as you're evaluating solutions.
And then like I mentioned, being able to
just plug in
leverage patterns like things like whether it's label
selectors,
owner references,
pod controllers,
Kyverno
is able to leverage all of these types
of things built into Kubernetes
to just be
a bit more intelligent and simple to use
in terms of what it does
policies.
So just a quick comparison
of languages and we'll see several examples.
On the left side of the screen is
OPA policy which
says
pods should have read only file systems, right?
And on the right side of the screen
is the same way you would declare this
in Kyverno.
And as you can see the pattern over
here, if you look at the bottom side
of the example,
it is very similar to what you would
see in a pod spec.
In fact, it's the same, right? So it's
using the spec containers,
security context, things which are very familiar.
And that's how you would declare what you
want to happen and then the engine will
make that,
validate that or enforce that on your behalf.
So just a general structure of Kyverno policies
and rules and again, as we go through
examples, we'll revisit a lot of these, but
at a high level,
policies
have multiple rules. Each rule has a match
or exclude,
and there's several criteria you can use to
match or exclude resources.
Now, Kyverno works as an admission controller.
So
when
it receives a request, an admission review request
from the API server,
it can apply some of these conditions,
But it can also look up
the existing namespace for example for the resource.
So the namespace selector will do that, but
some of these other criteria
will apply to the data in the admission
request itself.
And then once
the engine decides which rules applies,
each rule can either be a mutate, a
validate or a generate
rule and based on that there's more details
and logic that you can or declarations
you can have within that rule to
enforce your policies.
So fairly simple but powerful structure in terms
of how policies are organized.
And all of this is again because you
can write this in YAML,
you can leverage best practices like
GitOps, you can use customized,
kubectl,
just works very
well
with Kyverno itself.
So this is like I was mentioning earlier,
how Kyverno runs and the idea is that
the engine will cache
all of the policies that you have declared.
It also uses
Kubernetes machinery
to look up objects of course and match
against those resources as policies are being processed.
And then it produces the other interesting thing
about Kyverno,
policy reports are also fairly straightforward. I mean,
are custom resources as well. So
in fact, the policy report standard
is something being
driven in the policy working group with the
idea that other tools can also adopt the
same reporting standard.
So if you have like tools like KubeBench
or even Falco and others,
and perhaps even Gatekeeper in the future,
if they choose to, they can produce
policy reports in the same format,
which of course makes things much easier
for admins who have multiple tools running in
their cluster. And then Kyverno also updates, produces
events, produces and updates resources as it's applying
policies, things like that.
Yeah, so that's a general overview and I
can continue a little bit further or happy
to maybe
we can also go
bit hands on if this is enough content
or context at this point?
Yeah, we can switch to a conversation now
before we get hands on and just take
see if we can encourage a few questions.
Okay.
Okay. So
it's really, I guess it was good timing,
right? For this episodes.
Just yesterday I was on the Kubernetes office
hours and there was a lot of conversations
around pod security policies and then being deprecated
in the either 01/19 or 01/20 version of
Kubernetes.
Now,
you know why that is and is Kyverno
the answer?
Possibly, right? It's one of the solutions certainly
or potential
ways of managing
pod security.
So I think just a quick backgrounder there,
right? So pods of course being the fundamental
unit of execution of control,
each pod has a security context as part
of its declaration.
And then each container can further refine
or
over write certain settings in the container security
context.
So pod security policies control
what
can be specified
in that security context
within pods and within containers.
The reason why they're being deprecated, there's several
reasons, but the main reason is just the
usability of them
was somewhat questionable
because
one of the challenges was that, so first
off pod security policies to associate them to
a workload,
they leveraged
just the Kubernetes RBAC and authentication,
which is a very
nice way of doing things.
But it also meant that it was a
bit difficult to set up because now each
workload
requires an identity, that identity that's a little
bit fine grained, you have to map that
and then associate it to the right PSP
in
order to enforce that. The other challenge with
pod security policies is if you wanted to
roll this out, there was actually no real
good way to roll it out on an
existing cluster.
And there was no way to also test
it, so it was either an all or
nothing.
And there was a potential because of the
impacts of this that you might end up
enabling it in a cluster which causes
consequences.
So all in all and from some of
the, I think I'd seen an AWS
survey, a security survey,
which stated that about,
although pod security policies have been around for
a while,
think about 30 or 40% of users actually
even tried that.
And I think what we've seen in
a lot of scenarios is they're enabled but
not really bound to any workload, right, which
does nothing really to enforce security.
So those kind of challenges
is what the community is trying to address.
So there
are efforts with the Kubernetes,
SIG security as well as SIG auth.
There are a lot of folks working on
a potential replacement for pod security policies.
So the idea being that I think everyone
can agree,
it would be great to have something native,
which makes Kubernetes
as secure by default as possible,
but still allows flexibility.
So there will be some level of and
so
the PSPs
are being marked for deprecation
in version 1.21,
which will be I think it's in the
March timeframe when that will be released.
But the actual removal will happen in version
1.25.
So in that interval,
the SIGs and other folks working in the
community
are
reviewing
proposals for potential replacements
and also kind of trying to better
articulate
where other policy engines like Kyverno
or OPA Gatekeeper
can plug in. And what else would you
want to do with those, right? So the
good news is there will be hopefully something
better than PSPs that we end up with
natively.
And also
for more flexibility then you can lean on
things like Kyverno and OPA Gatekeeper.
Now in between and if you're a new
user getting started,
we believe of course that
most users should consider a policy engine for
a lot of the reasons we're talking about.
And it just both
policy engines we're discussing
make it fairly easy to get the equivalent
of bot securities
and they make these very configurable by namespace,
by workload,
so you get a lot of flexibility.
So it's definitely worth if you're starting with
the new cluster or going into production with
clusters,
check out Kyverno,
check out the OPA gatekeeper and evaluate both
of them
and pick one, right? Because it'll definitely help
with your security posture and there's just so
many things they can help solve with these
engines.
Awesome, that was a lot of great context
and history. I think that's, it's really important
for people to understand that.
And you know, I think I'm definitely on
the side that is favoring
more of this functionality being extracted from the
Kubernetes project and being spun out into other
projects or, you know, raising other projects up
to take place because there's a lot of
conversations in the Kubernetes community that the releases
are too fast for operations teams to even
go and
the one thing we don't want to slow
down if we slow down the Kubernetes release
is surrounding projects that focus on policy and
security and auditability and all of that and
I think it's really great that this kind
of trend is hopefully happening. So awesome.
Okay,
think we spoke a lot, so I think
why don't we get this screen shared, we'll
get Kyverno installed
and let's see what this thing can do.
So there
we go. Nice.
So in order to get started today, I'm
not using a, you know, real production
Kubernetes cluster. I'm using Docker for Mac and
we're just going to try and get Kyverno
deployed and then see how the policies happen.
So I'm going to click my favorite button
and every website is getting started.
Let's see, so the first thing we need
to do is just
because this is all Kubernetes,
it's just apply some YAML.
I'm gonna be very trusting and just throw
this straight at my Kubernetes cluster.
Do we think that kubectl dash f and
a remote URL is the same as curl
bash?
Is something I should be avoiding?
I seem to do a lot, I'm getting
a bit worried now.
Yes, so there is a Helm chart too
in our quick start. I think we have
given the example of just pulling the YAMLs
but I think definitely for
production clusters as a Helm chart option in
the installation section.
Oh yeah, definitely. I mean Helm, it's always
good to have a Helm option, but I
am more partial to just keep control, apply
most of the things.
Let's see what do we actually got? We
got a Kyverno namespace, we got some custom
resource definitions,
service account and some RBAC stuff and then
we got, I'm assuming which is the actual
Kyverno deployment,
service and a conflict map. So all pretty
much self explanatory.
And I guess we should expect to see
this
running at healthy.
So this Kyverno deployment that we got, this
is just, is this registering itself as the
admission controller that you kind of covered in
your slides?
Yes, it does.
So it will, once the pod gets deployed,
the deployment and service also get installed,
it will bootstrap itself as an admission controller.
It also generates a certificate.
All of this of course can be overridden
and configured with options if you wanna provide
your own certs, etcetera.
But the defaults, it'll just take care of
it.
So does that just generate its own self
same certificate and pass the bundle into the
registration,
Exactly.
You can also yeah. If you check for
the validating webhooks, you'll see that there's a
few configured registered.
There's also mutating webhook or I think a
couple right shooting?
Yeah. It's actually
validating web bug configurations.
Yeah.
There you go. I
don't know how I got that little bit
on the end, but there we go.
Yeah. So we've got Kyverno
policy validating and then a resource validating.
And
then it looks like the getting starting guide
is just gonna throw me straight into the,
I don't know if it's the deep end
or the shallow end but we're just creating
our first cluster policy
And
it looks familiar to what you showed in
the slides.
And it just seems to,
sorry, I minced my words here.
Is the idea with the policies to mimic
the objects in which you're applying the policy
to. I've seen when you were doing the
pod one is that I could probably have
just ran like some sort of YAML merge
with my actual pod and then
done some sort of assertion against it. Is
that common throughout?
Yes. So for validate policies,
one style that supported is this just using
this pattern block, which
will match the structure of the resource you're
trying to validate.
There
are a few other sort of things you
can do like you can use,
you know, there's a deny rules as well
as you know preconditions etcetera,
but the most the simple policies
are just mimic the structure of the resource.
And is it fair for me to assume
that with the existence of a cluster policy,
there's also some sort of names based policy
or is always just a cluster policy?
Is a names based policy.
Right.
Go ahead at checking.
Yeah. I'm just about to say the same
thing. We have cluster policy and names based
policy.
I like it and it's one of my
favorite things when I play with software, see
even my intuition can answer questions and I
don't need to have any knowledge
upfront. Always think that's great.
Okay. What did I get wrong here?
Oh, it's just is that a backtick?
I saw the policy is created. Yeah. Think
it's just the back the shell was expanding
Okay. This.
Okay.
Created that way. Okay. So let's just take
a look at this. I can run cluster
policies.
Yeah. And if I get our require labels
Alright.
So
let's see if I can look at this
and work out what it's doing.
So I'm assuming the name is going to
give most of that away but still we
are,
so we have some sort of match that
says only work on a pod resource type
with the validation that we expect for app
Kubernetes IO dash name label to exist and
we don't really have any constraints on what
the value should be.
Is this just regex? I mean it looks
like regex but not regex.
It's
it supports you know star
like so the splat and the question mark
characters.
So it
that's it's not full regex but just those
two characters.
So for either, you know, wildcarding parts of
your name or
allowing some variables in there.
Okay.
And now we're just gonna create a deployment
and we should see this fail because
this cluster policy mandates that we need that
label.
And I guess is that what the validation
failure action is? So we have enforced what
what else is the the options here?
We also have audit mode. So in enforcement,
if your results violate the policy, the creation
will be blocked and otherwise it just reported
as a violation.
Okay. Cool.
Alright. So my deployment
failed.
We can see what caused it to fail
and that the label is required.
Alright. Let's see. Let's add our label.
Simple.
Cool.
Alright.
That was yeah, let's just delete all this
then. That was good.
Nice and simple, easy to reason about, I
didn't have to go digging into documentation to
try and understand anything,
again that's really,
that's the way things should be with software,
right? It's supposed to make our lives easier,
it's not supposed to burden us with all
this new stuff that we really need to
go and learn.
Cool.
Great.
Alright, so that's Kyverno
one zero one, our first policy
looking for labels and denying it if it
doesn't have it.
Now should we jump into the writing policies?
Are we gonna take a look at some
more advanced examples? Maybe we could discuss
what
are the common use cases that you see
people using policy for within a Kubernetes environment?
Yeah. You you mentioned and we were talking
about PSPs.
So that would be a good thing to
explore.
Shooting. What do you think?
Yeah. Yeah. We can explore PSP.
Sorry, Igo.
Yeah. I mean, we have all the policy,
like, secure
pod security standards
available on our website. If you look up,
there is a policies
button
on the top.
The blue bar. Oh yeah. The third one.
Yeah. So it says prepackaged policies that people
can just come in and get. Yeah. So
I guess here's the question then like, know,
as far as Kubernetes clusters go and adoption
across different teams, organizations,
etcetera, like are the policies that people are
applying
Snowflakes, are they unique or is it fair
to say that the majority of people probably
want the same standards of templates or policies
to enforce the same things?
That's a good question, right? So we,
it tends
to be
that for things which are well
defined enough by the community like pod security
and I think as there a link up
here, if you click on pod security,
Kubernetes actually has a page which
defines
pod security standards
and different levels of pod security.
So
for something like this, it definitely makes sense
to just use the policies as is and
every cluster should have some implementation
of these pod security standards.
One implementation
of course is PSPs which we talked about
Kyverno and OPA Gatekeeper,
two other implementations
of these Pod Security Standards.
So
for something like that, it's definitely makes sense.
But the tricky piece comes in where like
so now if you have a workload, like
let's say you're running whether it's Prometheus or
NGINX and sometimes pods require
access let's say to a host directory.
And one of the rules in the
I believe in the restricted standard or actually
it's in the default standard
says that host path should not be used,
right? Because that creates some potential
security holes where if you have pods running
with host path access,
it's possible that an intruder can use that
to get access to host.
And certainly if you're using host path in
combination with things like privilege pods,
bad things could happen, right?
So this is where some flexibility
now is required, right? Because
in a cluster you typically wanna exclude
certain things, you wanna allow privileges
for very select pods
as a small of a subset as possible.
And so this is where customization
and that flexibility is required.
And then there are policies like best practice
policies which are just
best practice, right? So those are not necessarily
helping secure your cluster etcetera, but they might
help with other things like requiring probes.
They
can solve problems like a noisy neighbor problem
if you have a multi tenant cluster.
So those we have put into like best
practices.
And then there's finally
in our policy library, there's other category
which just contains like different samples that
come up and some of which are shared
by the community and we're constantly adding more.
So that's how we're roughly organized, but the
pod security one seems like the standard one,
which everyone should have.
Others are more up to administrators.
And I guess this is where that's you
know, that's like that we've seen in the
first policy we created where we had enforced,
but there's also audit is that you may
want to enforce all of the basic essentials
and then audit the
things you're striving to reach, the things that
we want to get better but we're not
quite there yet and then track them over
time. That to me seems like a pretty
good adoption strategy.
Right.
Yeah and giving
teams a chance to kind of fix things,
right. So what we've found very effective
with some deployments is just showing a report
and the Kyverno
these
policy reports and we'll see some of that
once we apply pod security policies.
They show up in the namespace
of the workload itself.
And the reason why we designed it in
that manner is so that the workload owner
gets a chance to see
which policies
there are violations for and they can remediate
and fix that. So the idea is that
in a dev test or staging cluster, you
can run-in audit mode, but in production you
would kind of put the brakes on and
run-in enforced mode and just block any of
this. Right? So
those sort of
that flexibility is also really nice to have.
Yeah, definitely. I can see that.
Okay. Let's go back to our our kind
of introduction getting started gate here. I can
see we've got a whole bunch of examples
on writing policies. So I guess we'll pick
a few of these, we'll work through it,
we'll try and highlight what's new in each
one and we'll take it from there. So
let's see.
Oh, that's a bit chatty. Okay.
So Yeah. One thing if you wanna try
real quick,
you know, if you go back to the
policy library, there's a actually a one liner
to install pod security that may be
So just click on that.
If you wanna grab that. So if you
have customized
running or installed just as a standard. The
customized version with kubectl is a little bit
old so it doesn't work in this manner.
But if you have local customize you can
just grab that and run that.
No, but I'm sure I can quickly grab
it.
Okay, cool.
Yeah, I haven't really installed customize on its
own since it was added to KubeControl natively
but I have seen a lot of chatter
especially recently I think there was a major
release of Customize in the last week Right.
In fact there we go it's the four
point zero so and there was a lot
of chatter into then.
Oh I think you got four point o,
so let's see if this works.
Yeah.
Why don't I not build it then? Why
don't we
will we raise it to fail and take
a look at it?
Sure. Let's take a look.
No errors yet.
Okay. That looks
did we get a YAML or Yeah. We
got a YAML. Okay. Perfect.
Yeah. Just want to make sure figured we
pop open and code, get some syntax highlighting,
hopefully make it a little bit
So
Yeah. So as you can see what customized
data is it just bundled
all of the default and restricted policies.
So yeah, you can now apply this to
your cluster.
Alright, we have a whole bunch of pod
security policies applied.
Shall we take a look at some of
the,
you know the actual policies themselves and just
kinda help people understand
the constructs
and the way that the build these out
and what they mean.
So Yep. I mean I see some annotations
here on the first cluster policy,
is that purely for the reporting aspects
that allows them to group them together?
That's right. And it's just also this
is we use this to organize policies
in our policy library. Right? So it's
optional.
But we recommend like using these just category
description just to make it easier and it
does carry forward in the report as well.
Okay. And then similar to the first one
we applied, we can see that what we're
doing here is targeting pods and we do
have a question from the audience on that.
So why don't I pop that on the
screen just now?
Frank is asking is if I have a
policy that I'm enforcing on pods, do I
also need to do that for deploys jobs,
etcetera, or will the pod catch it all?
That's a great question.
Yeah. So as
you pointed out, all of these are on
pods. Right? Chuting, do you wanna
talk about what happened to the Sure. So
David, if you wanna go to your terminal
and grab one of the policies YAML,
we'll actually see there are more than one
rules defined per policy.
So you just want me to get a
cluster policies
and then pick one.
By the way, CPOL is the short form.
Oh. Yep.
Oh, no. It's got a it's using the
prefix approach. Okay. There we go.
Okay. So now you can see basically we
have three rules
in this policy, but in the definition, yeah,
but we only have one for pod.
So what Kyverno does here is it'll automatically
convert those pod rules to the rule of
pod controllers
so that you only taking you only take
care of the
all the rules that apply to pod and
then Kyverno will automatically convert
it.
So just So everything
you apply to POT that will be applied
to your POT controllers.
Okay. So Kyverno kind of understands that when
we say POT, we really mean kind of
anything that runs and just expands that scope
for us as a catchall. Right, yeah, you
go back to the docs for a second,
there's in writing policies there's something called AutoGen
and this can all be controlled. So you
can put annotations in your policy,
you can manage exactly which pod controllers you
wanna target. You can turn this off if
you don't want this.
But the whole idea is to,
just for usability,
you don't wanna silently fail. So this was
another
gripe or common complaint with PSPs that it
was really hard to see errors. Like when
something failed, it's hidden in events or,
you know, the logs which are not accessible
to users.
So with Kyverno, we designed this to just
translate these policies automatically.
Okay. So
is that I'm just trying to work out
what this page is saying. So this rule
says only target pods
but really that's expanded to include jobs, stateful
sets, deployments and daemon sets.
Okay.
And you said there was a way to
control that if that's not the behavior that
I want.
Oh yeah. Right. Is this it here? So
if I don't want that scope
wagering by default then I just use an
annotation on the cluster policy and I just
say auto gen controller
to
I think it's disabled or something like that.
Right? Yeah.
I'm sure it's in here somewhere and I'm
just too impatient to actually read, but there
we go. Value of none.
Yeah.
Oh, by the way, you can use kubectl
explain.
So all of the docs,
because Kyverno works with CRTs,
if you say kubectl explain
cpall.
Spec, you'll see,
you'll get help for any field directly
through kubectl itself.
It's cpal, just cpal.
Okay.
And I can just do spec.
Dot
spec, expand sapo dot spec. Yeah. There we
go.
K. Kubectl is one of the kubectl explain
is one of those commands that I really
should use but I always forget that it's
a thing. Today
I've learned something.
Alright, that's really cool, I like that. I
like that scope
widening by default. I think you know when
people say pod what they're really just meaning
is kind of they want to apply generically
to most things
but of course there are occasions where people
would want to disable that and the annotation
is there to do that as well so.
Right.
Yeah, so I think like Frank was asking
so he can write the policy or just
that you know at the pod level and
then, you know, target different controllers or let
Kyverno just generate the defaults.
Okay.
I get
should we go back to the pod security
stuff we were looking at or is there
more Yeah. So let's actually I I would
say I think, should we try one of
the bad pods?
That's a fun example. Yeah.
Yeah. If we wanna see the policy in
action,
so we can apply some workloads.
That. It's provided by another
repo.
Bad parts.
Kyverno
maybe
is it ready to share a link or
you can search for buy shop box?
Sorry. I didn't catch the last bit. Buy
who? Buy
shop, b I s h o p,
Fox,
f o x. Oh.
It's
f o x.
S o x?
F o x. F s Sorry. Like feature.
I think if you just search for bat
box by itself, will yeah. Just it should
pop up. It
yeah. There you go. The first
link.
Alright. Okay. So this is a security researcher.
It's a great resource,
by the way.
Think
so if you get to their GitHub, you'll
see all the pod definitions.
You wanna go back and the second one
is the GitHub.
There you go.
And here it provides the manifest for like
kind of kind of bad parts. It has
some of the like security field defined, for
example, host pass or
like adding other security context.
So we can use one of the manifest
here to test the Kyverno policies.
Right. Got So which one should we pick?
If you scroll up, I think we already
talked about the host paths. Right? I think
that's
probably the So bad part four? You wanna
wanna Host path a little bit? Yep.
Me zoom in a little bit.
Yeah. Just choose
whatever
the manifest one.
Okay. So if I just grab
one of these,
you can see
oh yeah. So this has got a volume
that's trying to mount the fail system into
the container.
Mhmm.
If I just copied the raw path.
Now we've just applied
the
default
security policies we applied?
Yes. So that should be we expect this
to be blocked. We're gonna get an error
here saying that I'm not allowed to do
this.
And we did.
Yeah,
there's some
I guess very bad parts which allow everything.
Yeah, I mean this is a fun thing
to play around with and
that
webpage gives a great
explanation
of why certain things could be dangerous and
even shows you how you could kind of
exploit those settings.
Okay. So this failed in multiple rules then,
or I guess multiple policies, the host path
and then there's the check container one, but
we're running that route
and all just failed. So
like,
I'm assuming we could apply more of these
and we're gonna see similar things where it
just goes through and blocking them. So.
Right. If we just take a look at
some of these default ones,
like what do you see are some of
the challenges people have with
writing these policies?
So with actually creating these policies,
it's you know, just first off, obviously,
like the syntax. Some so by the way,
I think you see like this is a
good example. Right? So there's a little bit
of decoration
around
some of these tags,
right? And it's probably good to explain what
that means and the docs go through those
in detail.
We call them internally in the code, we
just call these anchors. So
what
they do is they allow conditional logic.
So really it's saying that if
security context is defined
and if capabilities is defined,
then
you want to enforce a particular setting, right?
It has to be set to
or
the X means it should not be set,
right? So
there's
a little bit of logic like that, which
is just added sprinkled on top of the
YAML,
which makes Kyverno
handle
conditionals.
So that is something that needs to be
learned. Right? It's fairly straightforward.
In most cases you would use like the
equal to and the parentheses
to kind of mean that if that tag
is specified,
then further proceed and evaluate the rest of
the rules.
So I think that's one thing which you
know, does require some
reading up on.
There's more advanced
logic,
and advanced sort of rule definitions which can
be done and, you know, we can look
at some of those examples. If you go
back to like writing policies,
there's a number of different constructs in there
which you can use for more
advanced logic.
And I guess that's right in policies page
in the documentation for someone who's new to
Kyverno and wants to understand those little
constructs that are different to what they're familiar
with and just working through the links here
is, is that gonna introduce them to all
of those different quirks?
Yes.
Yeah, so it starts with validation and you
know this kind of conditional logic for validation,
right? And there's different ways. So of course
match and exclude and things like that
is
the first section,
then it's on validating resources.
The more advanced policies and what we've seen
folks in the community start doing is
everything from injecting
sidecars,
adding volumes,
adding standard labels.
And then the other interesting pattern that has
emerged is
using Kyverno
to to almost do like an IFTTT
for Kubernetes. Right? So if a namespace has
a certain label
and that namespace is created, then you want
to start adding some defaults.
And even like one of our community members
was
writing a policy where
if that namespace was tagged with PCI, then
they wanted to make sure workloads running in
that namespace
would have the right node selectors. So Kyverno
can automate those things through generate rules.
So there's some interesting
possibilities when you start combining
some of these policies together,
like you do a bit of validation
to enforce certain constraints and patterns,
but then you also mutate workloads and you
generate workloads or
generate other resources on the fly as required.
Okay, so I've got one question,
there's also one question from our audience which
I'll throw at you both now
and then curious then if we can do
a couple more hands on things where we
look at the auditing aspects and the mutation
aspects of it and then we, I think
that shooting has slightly more advanced demos that
may be interesting to take a look at
as well. So,
Are we good? Yeah.
All right. Yeah.
So
my question is just about,
you know, I can see all the power
and the flexibility and kind of why I
want this and what I wanna do, you
know, I've already got all these ideas and
the first thing that comes to my head
is like,
what is the right
level of grouping these policies together
that really makes sense as I haven't tried
and tested there and let me try and
ask that with an example.
You know as an operator of a Kubernetes
cluster, I wanna enforce that there's a team
annotation on our label on all resources so
that I know which team gets paged for
whatever resource. But I also want to make
sure that they have some security context there,
they don't run as root. I also wanna
make sure that
they all have liveness
probes. Would
would I just have one monster policy that
I apply and say this is the policy?
Do I have one policy per one check?
Do I group some checks together? Have you
found this is a right or wrong way
to do that?
So there certainly are some best practices, right,
and kind of tying it just into code
constructs,
You know in any programming language of your
choice, you typically have something like modules or
packages.
You have then within those packages you have
files and within the file you could have
like methods or declarations,
right? So similarly with Kyverno and kind of
just thinking treating
policies as code as much as possible, you
would probably wanna follow that similar type of
organization
where you could have several Git repos with
policies.
You could have different packages
in those or different folders with different
types of policies.
And within that you could then group together
similar constructs.
So you can kind of start thinking of
policies based on the unit of like, and
you can of course version all of this
too and
use policies with either Flux or Helm or
whatever is your favorite way of deploying
stuff into clusters, right?
So I think that's a reasonable
way of organizing and
approaching things.
Like as you saw in
the library, we have organized things as a
pod security policy, where you would choose your
level
of security that you want and then entire
policy gets
to customize will just get pulled as a
single YAML,
which is fine. But
if you're trying to maintain those policies, it's
much easier to do things as smaller units
and you're just changing that
one smaller
policy rather than
trying to manage all policies as a single
file.
So I think there's no, like you said,
there's no real right or wrong answer. It's
just organizing
it and using coding best practices to
you know, kind of organize things into groups
and packages
and then within that dividing up further.
So would it be fair to say then
that when I'm writing policies
is that the
grouping of them is a human a human
thing and not a technology
problem? Like is there a performance problem if
I have a thousand policies with one check
versus one policy with a thousand checks?
I don't I don't see I
think so internally and shooting correct me if
I'm wrong, but we like the engine just
explodes everything into rules anyways. Right? And we're
caching rules.
Yeah. We're caching policies
actually, but in the engine, we're evaluating
per rule. So whenever your rule matches, it
doesn't matter if it's defined in one policy
or in a thousand policies.
Right. Alright, perfect.
Okay, let's take our audience questions. So Mozz
has asked
if I wanna have a cluster level policy,
but
met or you know, have special provisions for
cube system and any other name space, is
that possible to do?
Yeah,
it is possible to configure that. We have
the exclude block in each in every pop
cluster policies and namespace policies.
And if we wanna exclude some resources like
namespaces or the kinds globally,
we also have a config map that is
available for you to configure
any
re excluded list globally.
Would it be right with my naive assumption
and to say that the exclude is the
same format as this match here
with just Exactly. Okay. Cool. So you could
just copy
this, have match switch to exclude and then
add the name of your namespace.
Magic. Right.
Okay. So let's
let's play with an audit policy to see
how that works. I'm also very curious about
the background parameter we've seen earlier. Could we
maybe touch on that a little bit?
Yep. Sure.
Think you already have a policy installed,
but in in false mode in this case.
So could we write a policy that's an
order only, like a really silly policy that
checks the existence of a of a label.
Why don't we modify that, run it in
audit mode, and then see how we interact
with that?
Yeah. Yeah. So one other yeah.
Go ahead. Sorry. Go ahead.
No, no, you go ahead. So yeah, one
other thing, so any of these pod security
policies you applied, like for existing resources, Kyverno
is designed not to impact them.
So if you go back to your cluster
and just do like a get
policy report or polr,
p o l r,
you know, and do a minus a at
the end, it should show you if it
picked up. So there you go. You already
have some
reports created for your existing workloads.
So because Kyverno typically operates as an admission
controller, like it blocked in a new
pods which violated.
But if you had a pod running which
had a problem,
it will
it will just create a report. It won't
take down that pod or impact your existing
workloads.
So so yeah, this is an example of
one or we could write a new one
and apply it and see, you know, you
should also, it will produce a report.
Okay, so when I have a policy in
my cluster, whereas on audit mode instead of
enforce
there, there's no log lines from the admission
controller or anything like that. It just goes
straight into a report, which I should be
reviewing
there.
So I can imagine now if I wanted
an audit policy that says,
you know, ideally container shouldn't run as a
root user. If I wanted to write that
report to my
my Slack channel every time there was a
violation of that, Is that something that would
be possible using Kyverno?
So Kyverno doesn't do that notification automatically,
but there are you know other tools which
can watch resources
and then you know push notifications.
So you could use any one of those
tools.
So, and Kyverno also produces in addition to
the report, there are events which are sent
out for policy violation,
as well as
what there is a feature request
that I believe it was one dot 19
or one dot 20 that the API server
can now return warnings,
right? So for violations,
there was a feature request to
return back warnings on API server but allow
the
configuration to go through.
Whereas if you have the enforced mode, it
will just block and reject the configuration.
Got it. Okay.
I'm curious. If if I describe this policy
report, will it show me the
Yeah. Violations?
Yes.
I
had no idea where that was gonna work,
but my intuition wanted it to, and I'm
so glad that it did.
Yeah. So in fact, there's a one liner.
It's somewhere in the docs, if you go
to policy report, there's a one line command
which is handy to use to just grab
the violations.
And I think scroll down a little bit.
It's like, yeah, viewing violations. So just grab
that command.
Perfect.
And yeah. That makes it simpler.
Yeah. So that that's quite a good way.
So I I could and I'm sure other
people have already written, but controllers that have
a watch on this policy reports like the
alerting and notifying and stuff like that.
Right.
Okay.
Now when we were
applying
one of those pod security policies, I'm sure
it was in here somewhere. There was something
that said background false.
Did we I don't think we covered background
scans, did we?
No. We have not. Shooting you wanna take
that?
The background
scans
actually, it's gonna
produce a policy report that we already showed.
We already see that. Alright.
So it is physically report the violations of
your existing
resources.
Okay. If you turn this background scan too
fast, then we will not do the audit
in the background, but it by default, is
set to true.
Yeah. So one constraint to also keep in
mind is,
you know, so to by the way, Kyverno
has a CLI, so you can apply policies
in your CICD pipeline, right, which, is fairly
handy
if you want to, you know, just block,
things from being promoted in a build, etcetera,
or in a GitHub action.
So
the the one of the things we do
with this background flag is,
for certain policies if, you know, you can
have variables,
which either those variables can be populated
through
admission request data
or ConfigMap lookups
or even, you know, calls to the API
server.
But obviously in your CICD pipeline, you may
not have the ability to call an API
server.
So for those policies,
Kyverno will enforce that background
has to be set to false because that
policy cannot apply,
you know, that you cannot apply it sort
of just given your
so sorry, I take that back. For variables
which are not coming from the admission request,
background has to be set to false
because you don't have the admission request data
at that point, right?
So that's enforced
by when the policy is validated itself.
And you can choose then which policies run-in
background mode
with that one constraint
of any admission request.
Data you want to use within your policies
can only be done in the webhook or
the admission control mode.
Okay. Does that yeah. Don't know if I
explained that well enough or hopefully
it makes sense. No. I I think I
got that. Yeah. I think that made sense
to me.
Does
Kyverno
do people publish policies to the artifact hub
or is that something that exists now or
is coming?
So we're working on a process to publish
policies into
Git repo itself.
So there's a kyverno
slash policies as the underlying Git repo.
And the reason why we're doing that right
now is because we automatically
generate these web pages.
If you click on like that policies link
and you saw those three
groups,
there is you know, one of our community
members, he's working on a better way to
index these using those annotations and search these
policies,
which will
make it
very easy to kind of search for different
criteria and different examples of policies
find them.
So that's what we're thinking right now. One
other thing to add is in the chart,
if you install the Helm chart, there is
an option to
by default it
installs the default pod security policies.
You can turn that off or you can
set custom policies which was also another
community contribution which came in recently.
So
that's how we're so we hadn't thought about
just
publishing policies
directly on Artifact Hub but we Kyverno itself
as a Hemp chart is available there.
Okay. Awesome.
Well, we
are approaching about the hour now. So shall
we take a look at the demo that
you have prepared, shooting?
No. Actually,
what I wanna demo is the PSP which
we already went through. Alright. And I think
there are two
there are other two interesting features that Kyverno
can do as the mutate and generate ability.
Can walk through an example of that? Sorry.
My dog is going to say, don't know
if you can hear me.
The dinner time or
think there's delivery at the door. I'm not
sure. Oh, okay. Alright. So yeah. In fact
I kind of skipped over this earlier because
I forgot to mention again, but I did
see the variables, we did mention them in
passing, but maybe if we could take a
look at generating variables and
I've had this whole bunch of stuff on
this sidebar. I could keep you here for
the next few hours if you really want.
But
why don't we talk about the generate rules
then? What what kind of functionality does this
enable for people?
Yeah. Yeah. I can take this one. The
generate policy,
so basically, you will trick it'll be triggered
as
if you have any admission webhook common.
And then the generate policy will triggered,
and
you can
physically define any kind of resource to be
generated to your cluster.
And this way, for example, you can automatically
build your default modification environment
if a new namespace is created or else
it can generate some of the defaults
like our resources.
For example, the network policies or the limit
range,
etcetera.
So that it does some kind of automation.
So that's with this like as then this
that functionality that Jim kind of mentioned earlier
that people are starting to kind of build
out using
kind of Verrno policies.
It's a really interesting use It's not something
I had even really thought about or considered
when I was, you know, about policy within
Kubernetes but
it does make a lot of sense and
I think namespace creation is the one that
makes a lot of sense, I can already
think oh there's a few things that I
would want to generate into that namespace right
away that would make a lot of sense
so.
Right.
And with regards, is there anything else in
generate that you want to show? Can we
show this working?
Yeah, sure.
And then I wanna just bring out that
besides of generate, you can also clone your
existing resource.
So clone another resource from another namespace
or any other resource, I guess.
Right. Oh, I think that we lose shooting.
Oh, maybe. Yeah. Maybe.
Yeah. So you can you can your data
source can either be
another resource or you can have a data
block directly in the policy like one of
the example shows.
So I think, both options are
so yeah, why don't we try one out?
Right? Like, so let's, if you know, if
you wanna try it out, we can walk
through.
And
the one other thing to point out with
the generate policies is,
you can also have,
shooting's
back.
Yeah. You can also kind of keep things
in sync.
So if you, you know, one interesting use
case is, let's say you have,
you wanna apply secrets,
you know, some default secrets for your registries.
That's a common thing that people try to
solve in in Kubernetes.
Right? So with this Kyverno generate policies, you
can you can store those secrets as a
in a central place,
and then you can kind of have a
generate and sync function.
And when you rotate or change those secrets,
you just change them in that one source
resource,
and Kyverno will automatically propagate that changes
to all the namespaces that are watching or
that are,
you know, that clone that one resource.
Okay. Yeah.
Yeah. I see that why that would be
really powerful.
And I think serendipitously
as well, this example that I've just kind
of stumbled upon in this documentation
about network policies.
Also just immediately clicked to me like,
right in network policies is a major pain
if I you
know, if I
like I'm curious now, I wanna see what
is this generate thing is going to do
what I want but if
I have an image based and then I
deploy a postgres ql cluster to it and
I detect that that image is a postgres
image based on the name or the, you
know, whatever,
I could just automatically generate a network positive
that allows all traffic within that namespace to
speak to that database cluster, which is probably
not something I would ever wanna do, but
I could, is that right?
You can, yeah. And there is one other
example that we're seeing.
So just to kind of clarify one thing.
So the triggers for generate can be the
namespace creation
or you can use labels or annotations
in the namespace
to generate certain things. So
based on those,
can, you know, some interesting use cases like
one of our team members, he
automated
self-service.
So Bolero is a fairly popular tool for
doing things like backups of namespaces
and even allowing like backups based on a
schedule.
But one of the challenges is those backups
are scheduled happen to be at the cluster
level.
So what
he solved with Kyverno was just allowing
self-service for that by simply adding a label
to a namespace.
So the idea would be for developer or
a workload owner wants, you know, backups,
they would add that label and now everything
else just automagically
happens
behind the scenes because Kyverno generates backup schedule
and then Valero does its thing and and
you know starts backing backing
up the namespace based on that schedule.
So things like that are fairly interesting use
cases
which can now be enabled.
And is namespace the only resource that these
events like I couldn't I guess a service?
For creation,
I
think
yeah, shooting that we didn't enable
any resource now. Right? So for in the
generate block or
like as we see or like you
Mhmm.
Okay.
I mean, in the match block, can match
to any trigger resources.
Like, it's the same syntax
and define whatever results and kinds. And whenever
we see that resource and the emission request,
we will trigger this policy, generate power line.
Very cool.
Yeah. Namespace just happens to be the sort
of that unit of
separation
which comes up commonly.
Yeah. Yeah. I think I can think of
a whole bunch of use cases. Namespaces are
definitely lots of things we could do there,
but then services themselves and network policies. Right.
It's all this boilerplate stuff that you really
need to put into a cluster that
is typically really standard or doesn't deviate too
much from cluster to cluster, at least just
in my experience. So it would be good,
you know, if I could define policies that
can be consumed by any of my clusters
just to do all that for me. So
that's a really cool feature.
Okay. I think we were about to walk
an example. Do we still have time to
do that? Do you wanna Yeah.
Either
drive or Yeah. You
can just go ahead and copy the
I mean, install the policy to your cluster
and then simply create a namespace. Yeah.
Yeah.
That'll do all.
Alright. Let's just save
this.
So if I apply this and then I
create a namespace,
it's gonna create a config map which has
a zookeeper address and Kafka address.
Mhmm. Okay.
Create
namespace
Rawkode.
And then if I do a get all.
Don't think conflict map is
shown by default.
Yep. You're right.
So now we have a conflict map generated
because the namespace was created
and if I just do a quick get
on that,
we have our
I'm looking forward to that change that removes
managed fields from us, but I don't if
you've seen that in the next release.
Yeah, we have our data. Is it removed
again? Okay. Yeah. There's a pull request which
I think got merged yesterday that stops cube
control get from showing managed fields which is
a welcome to change.
Actually there is a plugin of kubectl called
kubectl meet and
you can attach it to your kubectl command
and so that it will strip out all
the unnecessary
fields.
Yeah. That's a great tip for everybody watching.
Just remove some of the stuff that you
never need to see or worry about. So
cool. Keep control neat. I like it. Yeah.
Did we have synchronizing the policy? So yeah,
if we had synchronize, you could try updating
the config or actually just change the policy
and see if the config map also gets
updated.
Oh, really?
That's interesting.
So
I don't know. C Paul.
What did we call it?
Z k.
So if I
scroll down here
and modify this. I mean, this is just
a conflict map, it doesn't really need to
be real so.
Right. Before I start typing random IP addresses,
Kyverno
one.
So synchronize
is something that I can add
to a policy.
Is that just an oh yeah. Here's here.
On the generate. So anytime I change the
policy, it's gonna go back and retroactively modify
the conflict maps. Now is that all conflict
or
just the ones that were created through the
policy?
Just the ones. Okay.
So does that mean there's some sort of
label on the policy that identifies it as
generated
on a So I believe the labels on
the yeah. On the resource.
Yeah. You can we can check that too
and Right.
Okay. And we got our synchronized here as
well.
Cool. Cool.
Does
that mean Kyverno can fix the age old
problem of a ConfigMap changing and restarting the
pods?
Not quite because
well, so you can change the conflict map,
you would still need to yeah, we don't
have a restart action and
need to somehow.
The number one question I get from people
that you know, go through Kubernetes workshops that
I'm working on or just chat and say,
how do I restart the pods when I
modify the conflict map and then all the
hacks you have to give them to do
it are always painful. Right.
So there is, mean you could, if you
change like an annotation on the deployment it'll
restart the pod. So yeah, yeah I guess
you could do that through a mutate rule.
Right, so you can combine your generate with
the mutate and
Yeah, that's always the way is to generate
a hash of the conflict map and sort
of some annotation Right. And things and
That works. But there's there's a problem for
us to solve another day. We don't need
to do that now in the next few
minutes. I wouldn't expect it.
Okay. So,
you know, we're kind of approaching the end
now and I don't wanna keep you all
much more, so maybe we could just have
a quick conversation for a minute around the
variables and external data sources. Is there anything
there that the audience should understand and how
those work or what they're for?
Yeah, those are certainly in a bit more
advanced but very useful features. So variables
you know can come, I think I mentioned
also previously through the request data.
So there's several examples of how, like for
one simple thing is
if you want,
if you're using like the namespace
or you're trying to look up things from
the namespace or in your message, even in
your output message, you wanna use that,
you can have variables coming from the admission
review request. Right?
So that's one example. Like just there, we're
showing the user info,
which is also super,
handy, right, if you want to apply policies
based on user roles, user names, things like
that.
The other source of variables could be config
maps. So with Kyverno,
we don't allow calls to any arbitrary external
system, Right? So you can't call like some
service running, you know, externally,
just to keep things bounded.
But what you can do is, you know,
you can have a separate controller which writes
to a config map and then Kyverno can
use that ConfigMap as a variable within a
policy.
So this is a way to create more
data driven policies
and ConfigMaps are fantastic
pattern in Kubernetes of course,
which Kyverno just embraces and and uses to
make policies more data driven.
The other interesting use case is,
if you, you know, go into the external
data,
there's a there's
ability and this was a recent feature we
added to do API calls. Yeah. So this
is explaining the config map feature.
And then, you know, further down is if
you,
yeah, want to look up things from the
API server.
So for example,
you know, if you want to do things
like, I think this example is talking about
oh, wait.
This is the yeah. Like, is that a
config map example? I think so.
Yeah. Yeah, so here we're,
yeah, just looking up, you know, using a
ConfigMap as a dictionary and based on certain
things we're restricting or allowing.
The other cool thing and you know, this
is,
you know,
I guess Jamie Spath or James Spath,
you know, is a fairly powerful free way
of processing
in a JSON and
it's also supported with group cuddle.
So one thing you could do with Kyverno
now is you can if you want to
call
let's say, know, this I believe this example
is just, you know, counting pods in a
in a namespace, but you could do things
like if you wanna make sure that you
only have a single load balancer type service
within the namespace,
you can make a call
through the API server, get all the load
balance services,
apply,
you know,
this JMUSPAT
expression
to count
how many instances you got and then allow
or restrict,
you know, the admission of another
service of type load balancer.
So things like that can be
done fairly easily and nice thing is you
can test all of this even with kubectl,
so you could take that same command almost
and of course replace request dot namespace with
your namespace.
Use kubectl raw to run that same command.
And you will see the output which will
be a bunch of JSON and then you
can apply if you have JP
install, which is the command line for James
path.
You can apply that and you will see
the exact pretty much everything that Kyverno is
doing internally,
programmatically you can try out and test.
Alright. That's a pretty advanced
feature but I can see definitely a few
use cases there for that.
One thing that struck me during the variables
one, you know, with you mentioned the user
that is creating the resource,
you know something that's quite common and get
ups environments is that
you don't necessarily want to block people from
applying stuff but because debugging has to happen
but at the same time
I would still like to be able to
audit or notify like would I
can I use the user that's applying the
resource to have one of those audit events
that says someone who is not the GitOps
service account tried to apply a resource?
Would that work?
So based on the user or the service
account, you would want to enforce
you would want to apply a policy? Is
that? Yeah, so in the policy and the
match statement, can I match against the user
that is applying the resource?
Yes.
Nice. Yes, so if you,
yeah, so in I think
in the selecting resources,
I believe we have an example of that.
Yeah.
So you could do it based on the
exact
user, the service account or even the group,
the user group that you want.
Okay, I'll take into the spec for that.
I just, there's something there that I think
I wanna play with at some point.
Sorry,
we're gonna say something?
Okay. So we have
one more question from the audience and then
I'll let you both get back to your
day. But this has been really really interesting.
I can already see loads of things that
I wanna start using Kyverno for and play
with. I'm really looking forward to continuing my
exploration.
First, we have a question from Frank. Frank
wonders if he can use Kyverno audit reports
or
met them as Kubernetes audit events
because he would like to consume them with
Falco.
Is that something that's possible? No.
So currently,
these reports are custom resources, so they are,
you know, created,
well, so you could the creation of the
report would go to the audit logs. Right?
So depending on how you've configured the
audit reports, whenever a new report is created
or the report is updated,
that will be audited and will show up
in the audit logs.
And you could configure perhaps more details so
you could have the entire body of the
report also show up there. So from that
point of view, yes, it will be it
is possible.
Kyverno doesn't directly,
write to the audit logs.
I know there was some discussion or there
was a proposal or cap for
allowing extensibility
and allowing external controllers to even write to
audit logs,
but that's not something that's supported today.
But you will receive again the the full
because it's a custom resource,
one of the value points is everything that
works for Kubernetes resources will show up,
in the audit logs and you'll see
when Kyverno is updating or changing
or you know creating a new report.
Awesome,
thank you.
Is there anything
either of you would like to say or
finish on before we wrap up for today?
Is there anything that we haven't covered that
you think would be useful for people?
So I think we covered or touched on
all of the most of the core topics.
Just kind of one thing to mention our
Slack channel and the Kubernetes Slack is fairly
active. We're
always on, so feel
free to reach out with any more questions,
thoughts, ideas.
And there's a growing and very active community
of folks and it's great that
there's a lot of people who are who
have been using Kyverno now for
some time and they're also very helpful on
there. So definitely would love to hear more
ideas and just to have people say hello
there.
All right, awesome. Well,
I had a lot of fun playing with
Kyverno. I wanna thank you both for coming
on today and sharing your knowledge with us
and guiding me through this exploration.
It's just such a cool tool and policy
is such an important aspect of Kubernetes customers
these days and I'm excited to see tools
like this coming into the space and solving
all of these problems so that we can
all write this code hopefully. That's my plan
at least anyway. So thank you again, it's
been an absolute pleasure, I hope you have
a great day and I'll speak to you
both soon.
You. Bye bye. You. Bye.